what's up guys we are pollinating today
we will be playing table tennis on an
egg-shaped table first I'll try to play
against Amy and then let's do two versus
one against Mika are you going wrong
apparently
[Music]
Bali does it count that's perfectly
legal an X table tennis
not really always back to the pit
that of this special shot inside out
back and with
okay now let's team up against me I
think we are gonna see some running in
this match
[Music]
good try though no I'm gonna get this
man
[Music]
yes I found the spot
no that's an evil with evil strategy
[Music]
all right
I feel it beats like a third wheel here
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
yes
[Music]
no to touch I think it touched sorry
sorry
[Applause]
No yea-ah
this is impossible I've shown me some
support by subscribing to the account
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
yes I went for a double
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
funny experiment firm no no no it's a
bit unfair we really enjoy that one
remember to hit subscribe and check out
previous videos there until next time